[Music]
if you enjoy what we're doing here at
spectator tv why not take out a
subscription
to the spectator magazine itself it's
the fastest growing
current affairs publication in europe
and within its pages and
on our website you can read all your
favorite spectator tv contributors
we'll even throw in a bottle of free
spectator
gin if you sign up at spectator dot co
dot uk
tv offer or you can just google
spectator gin
that's a subscription of 12 issues for
just 12 pounds
plus a free bottle of gin worth 30
pounds
simple arrhythmic arithmetic will tell
you that's a no-brainer
and as ever a very special thanks to
charles stanley for their continued
support
of the week in 60 minutes charlestown is
one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms one of
the oldest companies on the london stock
exchange we're delighted
to be partners with them now
covert june the 21st is earmarked as
freedom day on the roadmap out of
lockdown even nightclubs are to reopen
legal requirements on social distancing
should go
and thanks to the uk's successful
vaccine rollout
more than a semblance of pre-covered
normality beckons
or does it is the government changing
the goal posts already
is june the 21st still
a freedom day and a serious hurdles
to the continued rollout of the oxford
astrazeneca
jab emerging which could spook
government ministers further
kate andrews is our economics
correspondent editor of our daily
lunchtime briefing
it's the only roundup email you need for
the latest covered news
you can sign on uh via our website as
she pens this week's cover pieces
headlined
road map to nowhere kay joins us now
kate what's happened this
uh june the 21st day is not as bankable
for end of lockdown anymore is it
sadly no longer when the prime minister
laid out his road map it very much
seemed like the 21st of june was freedom
day the day that you'd be able to go
back to a nightclub go to a
mass event not have any uh cap on the
numbers of people who could gather
together
but in truth they left the really
difficult decisions for
separate reviews around social
distancing international travel
returning to work
and potentially bringing in vaccine
passports and we got the teaser this
week of their initial thinking in some
of these areas
and the suggestion was we don't know
when social distancing may lift despite
telling us for months that vaccine
passports were off the table
michael go said that he didn't know
anybody in government including himself
that was thinking
about vaccine passports a few months ago
now he's the one leading the charge to
bring them in
it very much looks like they're on the
cards and if we don't have normal social
distancing by the time we hit the summer
if we're having to use biosecurity
guards cards to access
um events to access the pub they haven't
ruled hospitality out by the way
and i think a lot of people will say
well that's not the normal that we
thought we were promised
that is not the full return of our
freedoms it would seem
that liberty is becoming conditional on
doing very specific things that the
government is asking you to do
and there was always a concern that when
we signed them away to tackle the
pandemic
to go into lockdown to save lives that
they wouldn't come rushing back
and despite the road map going ahead and
i'm sure many people are looking forward
to
being able to get a haircut or have a
pint on the 12th of april a lot of these
major questions about how free will
actually be
are outstanding but it's interesting
that this is happening in government
when the rollout of the vaccine has gone
better than they could ever have hoped
back in
january or even in february and i see in
your article you say that
both covet cases and deaths are down 95
since the most recent peak down 95
and that's an even faster decline than
in israel which has done even more
vaccination than we have pretty much the
whole population
has now been uh covered there and yet
there is this almost stepping back from
the original roadmap and in your article
you say it's all because they've taken
fright
at the possibility of a mutant strain of
the vaccine
of of the virus which the vaccine won't
handle is that really what's at the
bottom of this fear of a new variant
is very much on people's minds in
whitehall ministers are concerned and
the travel task force
is concerned and we got their first
update earlier this week about how we
might resume
international travel when it's legal
again it looks like we're going back to
the traffic light system or the
countries that you can visit
the summer and for the foreseeable
future without having to quarantine when
you get back
either at home or in a hotel we'll be
countries depending on
vaccination status infection rates and
also whether not officials think they
are vulnerable
to a new variant now the idea of
something new coming in and
wiping out our vaccine progress is
obviously terrifying
the difficulty in crafting public policy
is that it's based on a hypothetical
so far thankfully we have not seen a
variant that can undermine our vaccines
especially in those
crucial areas of preventing
hospitalization and death
so almost by nature these rules and
regulations are going to be indefinite
because you're planning for something
that might happen in the future not
necessarily based
on the facts as they are now so when we
can travel again it's certainly not
going to be normal and i don't think
it's going to be for quite some time
it's interesting that from the prime
minister down the the the emphasis from
government
is almost undermining their own strategy
the vaccine is not
a hundred percent effective uh
but as you point out no vaccine is
really a hundred percent effective and
when it comes to
um deaths and even serious illness
this vaccine pretty much is a hundred
percent uh
effective do they do they really know
what they're doing
so i think this is one of the most
concerning areas is that
what we're told constantly seems to
change matt hancock told the spectator
magazine in january
that he would be crying freedom once the
most vulnerable were vaccinated
grant shap said he would be on the
barricades to restore our freedoms
around a similar timeline that hasn't
happened
the prime minister said that we would be
open by easter because of the job
success at the end of last year
that hasn't happened but now something
even more worrying is happening it's not
just that they're pushing back this
timeline
we're told actually vaccines aren't the
full answer
and i do think that boris johnson and
his officials
sometimes come dangerously close to
talking down these vaccines
as you say andrew the fact that they're
not 100 effective
is is really not the point nobody in
their wildest dreams thought we would
get
a jab that had 100 efficacy that pfizer
is thought to be around 94 95 percent
effective that ultras astrazeneca is
very good and that they're preventing
against severe hospitalization and death
is a huge success it's a miracle frankly
that we have multiple jobs that are as
good
as they are and so if that isn't going
to be
what restores liberty and now they're
talking about the return of operation
moonshot which was estimated last year
to be a hundred billion pound project
we're going to be doing mass testing on
top of the vaccines but perhaps even
that isn't enough
we're going to have to have vaccine
passports potentially when does it end
and when can the public really see life
um
being not just back to normal but their
decisions their choices their lifestyles
being their own again
as opposed to what the state is saying
they're allowed to do it's
it's this shift in power that liberty is
now somehow
conditional and and i think that's um
what the cover piece is
is trying to look at this week just how
far down this rabbit hole do we want to
go before we say
enough is enough and government needs to
be transparent about criteria
and deadlines what they're actually
trying to achieve
you point out in the article how michael
gove ruled out
vaccine passports in december they met
hancock he
came out against them in january and mr
zahawi
the vaccine minister said there were no
plans to do so
um where are we now with vaccine
passports
so these cova certificates as the prime
minister likes to refer to them but
they're
vaccine passports or bioidentity cards
are
very much being considered the official
report that we got this week on the
status of the review
means that they are being considered for
a whole host of areas
not just around mass events but
potentially to be in hospitality
as well um we don't know the details
about how they would work yet although
we do know that you wouldn't necessarily
have to have your vaccine
to have one you could potentially have a
negative copper test or
a test proving that you had covered at
some point within a certain manner of
months
to suggest that you also have antibodies
the idea here is that it wouldn't be
fair to roll it out
if some people had had the jab and
others hadn't been offered it yet
especially because those people are
young people at the moment the under 50s
who haven't been offered the jab
they are much less likely to die if this
virus or get severely ill and so
there would be an imbalance there but i
think many will be asking
is it fair at all number one do you have
promised that this wasn't a
consideration
and now to be very actively looking at
how they might bring it in
and number two it seems like a very
short-term tactic to hand away that kind
of liberty and personal data especially
when they're saying
that vaccine passports wouldn't come
online until the summer at least
they're not coming online for the 12th
of april or on the 17th of may when
indoor hospitality reopens and hopefully
we can see more people inside
they're suggesting they'll come online
when we're supposedly free
and i think the idea of flashing your
uh vaccine passport um to a private pub
landlord or whoever to get into an
establishment there is even talk of
face scanning and in order to access
things that we're told we're free to do
won't quite add up to people
there's no talk of when vaccine
passports were first discussed
it was you would have to have some
documentation to show that you had been
vaccinated probably
had both jabs but now i see government
talking you've touched on
of biosecurity cards
which seem to be a lot more than just a
a bit of paper or an app that says
you've been vaccinated
is the government seriously thinking of
complicating things by going down this
line
so the prime minister was loath to call
them anything but
kovitz data certification at the press
conference on monday
he didn't want to call them vaccine
passports certainly not
bio-security cards and surely the reason
is
one of the reasons we can suspect is is
because the prime minister spent his
career
um adamantly opposed to such things uh
he once said that if he were asked to
produce an identity card he would rip it
up and eat it in front of the state
official that asked him to do so
um if you get this week's copy of the
spectator
we have assembled quite a few quotes
from the prime minister opposed to id
cards so i imagine it's very difficult
for him
to be the person who now might be
ushering them in to society but we can't
feel
too bad for him because at the end of
the day he is the person in charge and
he's the one
who makes the calls now maybe he's
changed his mind
maybe he thinks that they would be
useful now if so
it is not being communicated to the
public it is not at all transparent
what data or ideas are backing up this
idea because as you've mentioned
throughout our chat here andrew all of
the data is pointing in a really
positive direction the percentage of
people who have antibodies across the uk
is now
estimated to be over 50 and it's just
climbing because of our huge
vaccine success and i think a lot of
this can undermine trust if you're not
honest with people about your real
intentions
that nhs app that we were asked to
download last year and sold on the
premise that we would
help track and trace people who had the
virus in their contacts but that
information would be completely private
only you and you alone would see it that
app is now being talked about
as this new mechanism for vaccine
passports not only is the data not
private you're you're
sharing it but you're also with the
venues and establishments you want to go
into but
you're now uploading quite private
health data
into it you know that is a far cry from
where we were just
months ago and now i know a lot of
people out there won't have my
reservations they'll be completely on
board with something like this because
they think it will be a good mechanism
to help us get our freedoms back
but we need to have this very robust
debate at the moment these decisions are
being made by committee in reviews
this is i think a fundamental principle
that could change the way
we operate for months and potentially
years to come
and we might start to see that debate
the labour party
is for the first time in this pandemic
really starting to push back it seems on
this
point alone but you know we need to have
this discussion they may approve them in
the end they may not but we need to be
told exactly what their purpose is and
why they think now
at this point of the pandemic they're
necessary and then we can
approve or criticize let me bring in now
jamie
in joko goodwin he's the chief executive
of uk music it's an
umbrella organization representing the
british
music industry jamie welcome to
spectator tv
um what is your attitude towards vaccine
passports would that help you
reopen your businesses so for the past
year since march last year it's been
prohibited by law to have mass events at
capacity
um that's a huge impact on our industry
and the challenge for us
for the past six months or so has been
we can either put our heads under the
sand and wait for this whole thing to go
away
or we can look at different means and
mechanisms by which we could be having
events again vibing safely
so that's been looking at things like
ventilation better working guidance
testing but also looking at things like
certification
and i think it's really important that
we actually clarify what we're talking
about here because there's been a lot of
cross purposes about this debate is this
a vaccine passport to just prove that
you've had a vaccine now protected
or is it about certifying and
certification to show that you are at
less risk of transmission
i'm really compelled by the argument for
covert status certification
not actually because of the fact it
shows who's been protected but because
the increasing evidence that vaccines
can produce transmission
and then in conjunction with a test you
can be using it to show that spaces are
safer for social contact
and we've had a year of lockdowns and
which are basically a london crude
object
to stop uh social contact taking place
in spaces because government hasn't been
able to identify
who are the people who are at risk of
transmission inspires and who the people
that aren't
actually some sort of system where you
can identify who is
infectious who might be passing this
virus and who won't be
and therefore ensuring that rather than
lockdowns which mean a production
liberty for 60 million people
you can be restricting those
restrictions to the people who are
actually infectious
seems to me to be good from a public
health point of view sensible for the
large events and
settings like nightclubs music venues
and mass events which have been able to
operate for the last year
but also importantly would hopefully
reduce the possibility that you get hit
with a future wave in the future and
have to lock down again at some point in
the future
kate what'd you say to that well i think
if we lived in a world where
none of the vaccines had been successful
and the only way
to get back to some kind of normality
where through say mass testing
uh the idea of a coveted passport a
vaccine
not a vast passport in that circumstance
but some kind of passport to show your
coveted status as jamie says
might be a pragmatic one i think there's
still many ethical issues with it i'm
not sure i would
be able to support it but i think the
argument would be stronger
what's strange to me is that thankfully
we don't live in that world
we live in a world where we have
successful vaccines the uk is on the top
five countries for rate of vaccination
and it's the country where the most
number of adults want to take the
vaccine
there really should be no reason because
these vaccines work
by the time we get to the summer that we
would be looking at bringing in
something like a vaccine passport
when the data is on our side and when
the vaccines are on our side
and i worry about a short-termist look
at freedom you know well if we have this
vaccine passport we can get back to
normal
and and what we might be sacrificing in
terms of the long term
once this framework comes in this
apparatus comes in
what will government use it for they
already haven't been on us about their
plans to bring it in in the first place
and we don't know who will be in power
in five ten years time we don't know
what the circumstances will be
if we create this now under these
emergency scenarios even though we're
really moving in the right direction
i fear what it means for future freedom
not just freedom this summer
yeah so actually i'd read this as a
long-term strategy rather than just
become a short-term as one
um this shouldn't be seen as something
that's gonna be brought in for good or
permanently
but having this as a mechanism which can
either be turned on or off depending
where you're in a pandemic state
seems to me to be completely sensible um
it
there does seem to be a well i
completely agree with kate that if we
have a vaccine that is going to work
permanently isn't going to be affected
by a new variant then this wouldn't be
necessary and we could just open up
but the worry seems to be as with all
other viruses
increased transmission increases the
likelihood of a mutation
and you find yourself with the vats with
a virus and a variant that is going to
be virus resistant this is what happens
with flu it's why every year you have to
update your flu vaccines and develop new
flu vaccines
and when you've got a virus is as
transmissible as covid
increased transmission makes that much
more likely so i see this as a means of
mechanism of
trying to reduce transmission in a way
that isn't again not doing it through
lockdowns
not doing it through um increased and
sometimes quite draconian restrictions
by doing it in a way where you can have
normal life happening but with certain
mitigations without things like mask
wearing whether that's things like code
certification
but i think it's also really important
not just for now but for future
pandemics
um we're living in an age where if you
look at loss of biodiversity
increased international travel what's
happening with climate change
it's not me 100 years before we hit by
the next one of these things it could be
much sooner than we think
and a strategy in the future of we're
just going to lock down for a year wait
for a vaccine and
open up personally isn't good for
industries it's not good for individuals
and it's not good for anyone
um if you can have some sort of system
in place for the future that means when
you are hit by a future pandemic you can
have a testing system you can stand up
you can have a certification system that
says rather than having to lock down
your country for a year
you can identify who's infectious who
isn't and probably try and have much
more normal life
i think if you have this sort of
certification system this time last year
with a testing capacity and a
certification system by which you could
identify
who was going to be at risk of strenuous
virus you'd probably gonna be able to go
a long way without locking down bars
without locking down hospitality without
stopping mass events
and actually be able to be doing life as
normal so i view certification not just
a sign that's important for getting out
of this
pandemic but also protects and guarding
against having to lock down in future
ones as well
so kate what jamie's arguing there is
that
a version of a biosecurity card which is
what this would almost certainly develop
into it would be a necessary
tool for future for dealing with future
pandemics and if we have it
we might avoid the kind of lockdowns
that we've had to endure
in this pandemic well i'm not just sure
he's arguing for a biosecurity card but
a biosecurity state
i mean the world that jamie just painted
is one in which liberty is never fully
restored it turns out that our lifestyle
before was
too carefree too loose that we are
always going to need to think about the
next hypothetical thing that can go
wrong
and we need to make sure that people are
ready to get in line
to do whatever the government asks them
to do in order to tackle that
hypothetical
if you have this certification system as
jamie says and something else comes
along whatever
it may be what's going to be the new
certification
what is it this time that the state's
going to ask you to do so that you can
go to the pub so that you can go to a
mass event so that you can be free
we don't know what that future is
imagine to be
but let's hope that when it comes we
will have proper scrutiny
and debate and that people will have
some say and get to decide what they
think the right level
of risk is if we set up a system in
which
our freedoms are always conditional on
what the state
has decided is the appropriate level of
risk we are never
going back to the way it was now i think
you can make that argument in fact this
is exactly
the debate that i think needs to happen
over the next few weeks and months
do we want to trade away all of that
liberty for security and you know
plenty of people will and i think that
there's an argument to make but
let's be very honest about what that
future actually looks like and let's not
call it normal let's not even call it
the new normal it would be the
introduction of a biosecurity state in
which
it wouldn't matter if the evidence was
on the government side it would only
have to be a hypothetical
it used to be the case that if
politicians wanted to infringe on your
freedom
they had to present that argument they
had to make the case
and they had to convince hearts and
minds but now we're saying that that
power is flipped
we'll only return it when you can prove
that it's safe enough to return it that
you can prove
that things won't go wrong and i think
that is the wrong place
to put the power i think that we that we
need to flip that back
uh because otherwise as said we don't
know what the future looks like in 10
years time we don't know who's in charge
we don't know how they'll want to use
this
so to bring it in in these circumstances
i think
could in the future go badly wrong jb
final word to you
i think a lot of people may conclude
that what you are going for
is really id cards by the back door but
actually
a lot more intrusive than id cards
because they'll
contain a lot more information than tony
blair when he was arguing for id
cards ever envisaged it would be id
cards on steroids
so i mean i first need to say completely
with kate this is a debate actually
needs to be had
a discussion needs to have quite openly
there's a lot of ethical and legal
regulatory issues that people need to be
talking about and having an actual
debate on
um for the past year maybe i like the
pub too much maybe i like bars too much
but i haven't been sat there thinking
that stuff is closed but at least i
don't have to share my search my code
certification status and we're living in
a pandemic where difficult decisions are
having to be taken
but the focus is having to be what can
you be doing to be able to make
sure things are safe and not at risk of
of increased variance and future waves
um i don't see this as a biosecurity
state we're currently living through
a world where the government is doing
1.5 million tests a day
now make sure you be using that testing
with those testing results and using
that testing capacity in a way that can
identify
how people can be kept as safe as
possible and again i don't see that as a
biosecurity state all that
sort of stuff is already happening it's
making sure that the work that's being
done
is being utilized as effectively as
possible to prevent the threat of
um of future waves but also um to return
from the liberties i think lots of us
have missed over the over the past year
but i completely agree
it's a debate that i think a lot we
should be having and that um
i think okay okay are going forward very
very well
well it's a debate we've had here in
spectator tv and we'll come back to it
jamie and joko godwin uh chief executive
of uk music thanks for being with us
today and kate andrews of the spectator
thank you as as well
[Music]
you